See if it works. Can someone help me in checking
if it works? Yeah. Cool. So, thanks for joining.
This talk is about how ad blockers are being
circumvented and basically what we're doing
to fight back. What are the challenges that
we face on a daytoday basis and then what
are we trying to do to counter them?
A little bit about me. I'm product owner of
anticircumvention which makes plus, and previously
I was head of R&D where I basically tried
to use technology for making some solutions
for people with disabilities. And before this
I used to work at Opera. Amongst many things
also being part of the extensions platform.
So, an entire micro industry has basically
popped up in the last few years promising
to bypass ad blockers. So, basically, they
go to publishers and say that even if your
site isn't on the user's ad blockers white
list, we can still find a way to show user's
ads. Generally, if you go to their websites,
they'll say something we cover blocked ad
impressions, cover your blocked ads. This
is more of a problem. Back in 2016 there was
a research paper that analyzed this. We found
that at least 6.7% of the top five websites
engage in some form of anti-ad blocking. We
call it circumvention. It's at the next level,
rough privacy badger, and others that are
half of the ad blocking scripts in the dataset.
This was back in 2016. It's believed in 2019
this has scaledeven more on both sides.
So, you have more people engaging in this
kind of behavior. And there's also increased
amount of attention from ad blockers trying
to look at this particular problem as well.
So, what exactly is circumvention? As I said,
it's showing users ads by getting around the
ad blocker despite them not being on the ad
blocker whitelist. Either implicitly or explicitly.
Now, for obvious reasons this is bad, yes.
But there are some nonobvious reasons why
it's even worse.
To talk about this, or to think about this,
let's look at some types of opinions towards
ads and ad blockers. So, on the one hand,
you have some people who are just fine with
that. Either they don't know about ad blockers
or they don't care. Or they, as a matter of
principle, don't want it use ad blockers.
I know a few people like this. On the other
hand, on the other extreme, you have people,
what I call the scorched Earth mentality.
Where every ad is bad all the time and block
each and every one of them. Don't support
any online ads, don't care about publisher
revenue. And this is a spectrum. There's something
in between where it's like, okay, most ads
are bad. But not all of them are bad. As long
as someone respects me and is not doing annoying
stuff, then I'm willing to give them a chance.
And there's a lot of movement within the industry
to somehow take these ad companies and try
to make sure that they follow some kind of
standards or some kind of rules for good behavior.
Whether it's the coalition for better ads
or whether it's acceptable ads or something.
Let's take a look at one of them, called the
acceptable ads criteria. No matter how big
and powerful you are, no matter how much money
you have, it doesn't matter. At the end, if
your ad has to be as part of the acceptable
ads criteria, these are things which are not
allowed. And this is not an exhaustive list.
These are just some of the things. Animated
ads, automated ads, expanding ads, popups,
pop unders, these are not allowed no matter
how much influence you have. Now, ityou
can circumvent the ad blocker, you can do
anything you want. You can make your ads as
intrusive and as annoying as possible. And
that's what we've seen. When it comes to circumvented
ads, these are the worst of the worst on the
web and make things miserable for people online.
This is why circumvention is maybe worse than
what might appear as obvious.
Before we go, let's talk about how ad blockers
work on a very, very high level. You have
a web page, it has ads. You have a browser
extension installed. It's an ad blocker. What
it does is updates from a filter list which
is a communitymaintained list of filter rules.
And if that site matches that filter rule,
that piece of HTML or whatever is blocked,
right? And that's how you see a page without
the ads.
Now, generally the biggest one, communitymaintained
filter list is called easy list. But when
it comes to circumvention, we wanted our own,
we launched the anticircumvention filter list.
It's to target circumvention. We wanted higher
privileges to do more complex stuff. And it
allows us to react extremely fast to circumvention.
If you see circumvention, we can push out
a change and it's there instantly. User cans
generally update this by default every 60
minutes so it's regularly up to date.
So, as we're moving fast towards circumvention
and pushing all of these filters, CV providers,
or circumvention providers, they're forced
to become faster too. So much so that there's
a constant war going on between the ad blocker
and the CV provider. In terms of we push out
a filter to block their ads, they change the
content of the website. We once again push
out a filter, they change things. So, this
goes on and on and on. And they keep an eye
on the repo, it's open source. Anyone can
take a look. They constantly keep an eye.
One example of this is where one of our colleagues
who pushes out a lot of filters on a particular
website, had he found the source code, he
found his GitHub username as one of the classes.
So, make going to a website and view the source
code and see your name over there. And this
was kind of like I think from that website's
end, kind of like a wink, wink, nudge. Okay,
we know what you're doing now, and this is
kind of like us acknowledging you.
So, this is all about filters. But, you know,
it's a constant cat and mouse game between
ad blockers and circumvention providers. And
somewhere in between this game became more
complex. So, it's not just about, you know,
the cat chasing the mouse. There's just stopped
and started playing chess. So, things are
becoming a little bit more complex.
So, now we're gonna talk about snippets. There's
so, snippets are basically small JavaScript
functions designed to counter one or more
circumvention techniques. Generally, they're
use when had just writing a normal filter
isn't enough. So, you have to do something
more complex. And a significant amount of
the filters in our filter list is, you know,
using snippets. Snippets are also called scriptlets
in the block origin, for example. And if you
want to take a look at the source code, everything
is open source, this is the URL.
Let's look at case Studies of what we have
to deal with on ad blockers on a daily basis.
There was this one CV provider which at no
time want you it take a look at what they're
doing, right? So, what we did was kind I have
like a jujitsu move using their own energy
against them and I'll explain about it in
the following way.
So, the CV provider, what they used to do
was, whenever you try to go tots website and
open up the developer tools, they used to
detect this and basically clean up all their
code, remove the ads so that you cannot even
try to understand what's going on. You cannot
even debug the code. Which is when I found
out I was like, what the hell is going on?
So, we thought long and hard about this and
then we tried to use their own things against
them. We developed a snippet which tricks
the developer tools into being already open,
when they're not. They did the work for us.
They just removed the code themselves.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah. Since then they've caught on to
this, so they no longer do this trick. But
it was quite effective and quite funny for
us as well. Another thing I want to talk about
is something called the abort and property
read, or abort and property write. Typically,
a lot of these sites or CV provider, they
want to access a particular property or write
to a particular property. So, what we do is
we kind of know which ones they're looking
for and we made a script to kind of block
the script or abort the script as soon as
we detected they're trying to read a particular
property or write to a particular property.
This idea was originally from the block origin.
Even though our implementation in AVP is different
from theirs. But the overall idea was from
there and we give credit over here as well
as in the source code and good on them for
doing some wonderful work.
The next thing that I want to talk about is
superfluous element stuffing. So, there are
a few highprofile websites, not just one.
But a few. Which try to get around the fact
that, you know, you have posts and you have
tomention which posts are sponsored. So,
of course, if it's just the normal text, you
can search for the text that says sponsored
and that's the end of it. But they end up
stuffing a bunch of elements. They break down
the word sponsored into different parts and
then they do something like this. So, make
things clear a little bit more, this is what
they do. So, as you can see, there's some
divs, there's some spans. Some of these elements
are not going to be visible. The in ends it
will say ""Sponsored"" visually. But the source
code says this.
How do you deal with this? It's really frustrating.
It bloats up the page. It doesn't help anyone.
This is an approach that is gonna be there
soon in AVP. We're still making a few adjustments
here and there. But basically, what you did
is you go through all of these child elements.
And first what you have to do is remove the
invisible stuff. Stuff that doesn't really
stuff which is what we call decoy elements.
You check for invisible text, opacity zero
or font none, check for invisibility or collapse.
And you ignore those. You go through the ones
that are invisible and take the inner text
and you concatenate them. And if it says ""Sponsored,""
then you have your sponsored ads. Then you
can do whatever you want with it.
This is the kind of stuff that ad blockers
have to deal with daily. But this was still
okay. There's another example someone said
that, okay, we have sponsored posts and we
have to make sure that this says sponsored.
So, instead of text now they have something
where it's just an image. And inside the image
there's text. And it's really bad for accessibility
because it doesn't even have an alt attribute.
They don't care about anything. Even then
it will be okay to detect this, but what they
also do is, you see this blank space? That's
also an image.
That's the same PNG image as this one. The
only difference is that this is a transparent
PNG so you can't see this and the other one
is a nontransparent PNG so you can't see that.
So, it looks a little like this, it's a data
URI. And it's going to be really, really difficult
to detect what's going to happen over here.
And to make things even more complex, they
make minor variations in the way they're serving
images. In this example, this data URL for
this data sponsored image can be any of the
three data URIs over here. And same for the
data labels. It can be any of these things.
We had to look into the PNG spec and do a
lot of work. Ultimately, we found out some
kind of pattern which was only applicable
to the visible sponsored image.
And then what we did was basically it's just
a matter of taking that image, converting
it to a basis before, looking for that pattern
and matching it. If it does, then bingo. We
have our PNG ad label and then do the blocking.
So, yeah, there's a lot of stuff that we have
to do with, you know, circumvention on a daily
basis over here.
So, let's look at some gaps and challenges
that we have. So, when it comes to this, we,
you know, when it comes to circumvention,
the effort is being fought on multiple fronts.
It's not just one thing. So, we have people
who are working on kind of reverse engineering
what they're doing. You know, people who are
hard core JavaScript people. And then filter
list authors pushing out filters on an hourly
basis. And then there's many other things
that I will talk about in the next few slides.
On the other hand, even though we have some
really smart people working for us to kind
of deal with this situation, they also have
some really smart people on their end. And
they're willing to go through many creative
lengths to get around the ad blockers.
It's a daily challenge to keepup with what
they're trying to do. And as I said, this
thing is being fought on multiple levels.
Not just the technical level. Recently there
is this landmark Supreme Court case. Basically,
what some publishers wanted to do was to kind
of argue that ad blocking itself is illegal.
And they, you know, went through the lower
courts, the higher courts and ultimately to
the Supreme Court. And ad block plus was at
the vanguard of this and basically argued
that, no, it should be legal. And the Supreme
Court of Germany said that, yes, it is actually
legal. And, you know, it's totally okay to
use ad blockers and do ad blocking.
So, yeah. When it comes to fighting, you know,
circumvention fighters or publishers, a lot
of times what you have is not just people
using technical approaches, but sometimes
these kind of legal approaches as well.
Gaps and challenges? So, apart from this thing,
one more thing is the fact that in Firefox
you have an API called the content scripts
API. Which means that you can have a reliable
way for the extension to for the extension
to run always before the sites code which
is actually good in these circumvention things.
But in Chrome, you don't have an equivalent
API so there's no reliable way to guarantee
that the extension scripts always runs before
the site scripts. So, that's that. But there's
also the Chrome manifest V3 situation where
there are some significant architecture changes
that might be coming which will be impacting
a lot of ad blockers.
Some with welcome. The background page architecture
might be displaced by a service worker, which
is good. There's a switch to a promisebased
API rather than a callback API, which is also
good. But there are some major changes to
the blocking portion of the web request API.
So, this is the part of the extensions API
which allows you to block a network request.
And this is something which is going to be
or at least announced to be changed. Instead,
they'll have a declarative rulebased instead,
which is I think Apple. From most of the ad
blockers, if you read their opinion, it's
still not in a good enough shape right now.
And updating the rules from the filter list
might require a new version list. Right now,
if you want to update the rules in the easy
list, all you have to do is update the easy
list. It's there. But if you have to do this
new v3 thing, if you have to update the filter
list you might need to do a whole new extension
release and send in the extension to the Chrome
web store once again and gets moderated and
released. And if you have to do this each
and every day multiple times a day, it's going
to be impractical.
So, we worked together across ad blockers,
Adblock Plus, Adblock Adguard, Ghostery
and two authors, Fanboy, as well as Malwarebytes.
We gave the Chrome team feedback on one of
the things we would like in v3. What are the
changes we would like? It seems that the Chrome
team is taking a look and kind of evaluating
all of this. But at the same time, there's
a question mark over here on what do they
really want to do? What is the what is the
end goal when it comes to ad blocking and,
you know, when it comes to v3, what exactly
do they want? What is the quality that they
want in terms of ad blocking?
There's this performance argument that, okay,
you know, we want to make these changes because
we want to make things a little bit more performant.
There's the security argument as well. But
at the same time when it comes to ad blockers,
if the ad blockers are harmed, then circumvention
rises as well, and everyone is in a bad situation.
Whether it comes to this, I'll just end with
this recentlyreleased W3C tag ethical web
principles document which is something that
every browser maker everyone should read.
But especially all the browser makers should
read. It says that people should be able to
render content as they want. Users should
be able to install stylesheets, assistive
browser extensions, blockers of unwanted content
or scripts of autoplayed videos. Through technology
such as browser extensions, people must be
able to change web pages according to their
needs. So, with this I think this is a pretty
good way to end the talk. If you have any
questions regarding all of this, I'm here
after this talk and tomorrow as well. So,
I'll just say, thank you so much.
[ Applause ]